all of us were parented for many of us
it went well we were loved our views
were respected our needs were tended to
it helps to make us the more or less
same people we are now but for others
among us things went really rather badly
wrong perhaps there was unreliability
anger humiliation violence or worse if
there was were liable to have been
deeply marked we may even if it all
happened quite a number of years ago now
keep noticing new ways in which the past
is getting in the way of a good life in
the present our inadequate parenting
experiences undermine our ability to
have sound relationships the right sort
of confidence and to extend adequate
nurture to ourselves we would like of
course to move on there is something
unbalanced and deeply cruel in the idea
of the first 12 years determining the
next 50 we cannot change the past but it
does remain open to us to correct at
least some of its repercussions we may
learn to do this through a neglected and
yet deeply powerful process we call re
parenting how our parents behaved will
have laid down a template in our minds
about how we should respond to
challenges but we don't need to remain
forever stuck with a kind of care which
we imbibed in the early years we by
nature have an ability to parent
ourselves what this means is an ability
to comfort ourselves at moments of
difficulty to interpret the troubles
that beset us with imagination and
kindness to encourage ourselves in the
face of anxiety and loss and to reassure
the more fragile agitated parts of us by
drawing upon our experience and our
serene aspects all this is what good
parents naturally do for their children
but if this didn't happen to us we can
still in adulthood step in and do it for
ourselves one part of the mind can speak
to the other one part can act as the
sane resilient counterweight to the
bruised and more immature side of the
self
we can figuratively put an arm around
our own shoulder our experience of the
shortfalls of our own parents offer us
an expertise that is wasted if it stays
stuck at the level of just criticism it
should become the template for a far
more useful project the creation of an
inner ideal parent who acts in all the
ways in which the real thing should have
done but didn't quite knowing so much
about what we did not have enables us to
be experts at what we need and should
believe we can provide for ourselves we
already have the perfect inner parent
it's simply in many ways the opposite of
the one we had though childhood is a
one-off event in material time in
psychological time it's endlessly
requiring the eight-year-old us is still
there and we can talk to it and respond
to it in a way that allows it to mature
and strengthen in the way it always
should have done we can dare to make use
of a much underestimated capacity that
of re parenting ourselves if you liked
this film please subscribe to our
Channel and click the bell icon to turn
on notifications follow the link on your
screen now to see our range of books
games and gifts all about self-knowledge